are you a fan of global travel and going
anywhere in the world
why because now surf shark can let you
go anywhere in the world digitally
shout out to surf shark who have once
again sponsored
true news big thanks to them they look
after us yeah so we have to look after
them namely you
yeah you gotta help the soap if you want
the free content what was that sorry
what is surf shark oh it's nap and
browser extension that lets you
basically place your laptop anywhere in
the world so you can access things that
maybe you can't access from the country
that you're currently in
and that's perfectly fine exactly
anywhere yeah exactly where you want to
be
done brilliant you're right you want to
be in the united states brian yes
you say you want to be in the united
states because you want to be able to
access the netflix over there that's
absolutely fine
yeah you can see all the netflix series
or you say you want a clean
web brian you can surf in us in a cyber
in a clean cyber ocean with no ads and
no trackers or malware and there'll be
no phishing attempts that's where people
try and get your data
yeah so they're going i want your data
and surf shock again get hot girl
leave it at yeah you can also have it
across underneath ricky
ricky what was their name bianca bianca
they're the bianca of the internet leave
my little children though no one will go
well they will there'll be some 50 year
olds watching this and the good thing is
you can also get it on unlimited devices
how many devices
unlimited it doesn't matter how many
devices you've got what goes across them
all
ten twenty three yeah whatever you want
have you got a mobile phone and a laptop
and a tablet and another mobile phone
because yourself a burner phone because
you don't want your girlfriend to find
out do you texting then you can have it
across
all of them like any self-respecting
mind right well not all you're going to
do
one phone on the lot you can also be as
they say on here on the website that
i've gone to
great link whitelisted allow specific
apps and websites to bypass the vpn so
it works great with things like your
mobile banking
which needs you to be in the uk for your
own safety all right so you can just
select what you want to be in england
and then you want to be in america yeah
exactly yeah it's your own form brexit
it's your own brand like a nipple don't
think that's what surf shock are going
for they're not going for tweakable
nipples
although you can also see tweakable
nipples through so they want to surf if
that's what you want yeah you can see
anything
yeah honestly yeah no one will ever find
out yeah and you you've seen it all and
you right away on the internet on the
web
and the cool thing is encrypts your data
so you can stay anonymous online so say
that you don't want people knowing who
and where you are going
use this easy so what are you worried
about no i've got surf shop nothing
yeah and of course if you want to sign
up then what's the code
well laurence i'm glad you asked because
you get three months free extra when you
use the code geordie good
uh the checkout 85 off as well wow so
you've made that crystal clear
bomb bomb 85 percent or three months
extra frame rate
there you use the called jordy put it
there all of that all across the face
yeah so big thanks to so shocked once
again for sponsoring true news and of
course
it would nature news without some true
news so on
with true news
as if 2020 couldn't get more mental or
any worse
jake paul is fighting on a mike
tyson cod you know iron mike tyson the
guy who was wrecking [__]
and was the youngest heavyweight
champion of all time wow the
the podcaster host of hotboxing yeah i
thought it was just podcasted is it nice
he is getting the gloves back on in his
50s and he is fighting
legendary box out roy jones jr junior
imagine how senior feels
people are a little bit wow what the
[__] is this a good idea for mike
tyson's health
and then just to [__] it up a little bit
more and make 2020 a little bit more
crazy
throw jake paul in the mix he is
fighting weirdly
an nba player nate robinson now nate's
not been in the nba for a couple of
years but sure
this is how nate looks you're a big sort
of fan of them
who'd have thought that this year could
get any better for me a child a
championship
everything else and now the crossover is
real guys the crossover is real
he's been waiting for this moment he's
been carrying me for years now it's time
for me to carry you
got no idea about this guy well let me
tell you a little bit about [__]
nate robinson has been staying in shape
for some time on the outside hope that
an nba team goes
we don't have a point guard anymore why
is he all of a sudden fighting
nate robinson's 36. this is the this is
the thing right is when when youtube
boxing happens it's a little bit like oh
it's a little bit of fun again
when an actual athlete gets involved on
the one hand it's like
he's a legit athlete like maybe he could
cause jake paul some problems here
on the other hand 36 can't get a proper
job in the nba
and it's it's tinging on the pathetic is
it what no it's not
no other nba players be looking at him
going all right man you're fighting jake
paul what are you doing now with
yourself
it's hard to find an equivalent nate
robinson has always been a guy who loves
the spotlight he's won three dunk
contests in his time there he's traveled
around it's
like steven gerrard came up with i'm
fighting jake paul everyone be like what
yeah but that is because footballers
look uncoordinated nate robinson nate
robinson's done cardio moved his arms
for his whole career
yeah i i did see him um hitting pads and
i thought okay you've got coordination
there
right what you should expect from an
athlete yeah
he he's legit athlete and i mean that
picture makes him look [__] shredded
but he is a short guy that's the only
thing the guy's five nine
okay so jake paul what is jake paul
about nearly six foot i'd say jake paul
is there for just a little under my
height so i think he's about six foot
yeah so jake paul is going to have a
size advantage on this guy
right but this guy is a real bonafide
athlete although jake paul is very
athletic
if there's one thing i'll say about nate
robinson great way to sum him up
journeyman
never really quite cut it at the very
highest level or was it a very solid job
for teams can you show me this highlight
of this dunk that you could buy oh well
there's
so there's some dunks and then there's
some blocks nate robinson okay
get out of here okay that is impressive
this guy's used to powerful explosions
he's got power in his legs
i don't know maybe you know whether
power in the base of your body
translates to power in the upper
community
scientifically speaking that is where
your punching power is going to come
from is the movement so
i did watch him hit pads and i was like
not seeing massive power there but let's
see what else you can do okay
the other thing is he's not going to
struggle for footwork let's put it that
way yeah definitely
robinson the grandeur of robinson in
five
nine this guy has to be explosive in the
moment he has to read the other guy's
movements he's been doing that for his
whole career think of that
boxing again oh my god oh my god
that is sick yeah look at him he's he's
above the rim there that's impressive
for a guy who's five nine
here you go here it goes here we go wait
for it wow
oh my god he's the tallest guy in the
nba look at that that was a damn mugging
in the woods of trio that was lovely you
have to be a bit of a showman in order
to win the dunk contest this was his
first win in the dunk contest he was
drafted 2005.
so this is a young guy 14 years ago so
we would have been early 20s 22.
oh spins right can jake paul do that no
yeah
date probably not he can't do that could
you punch him in the face i think so
jumped over a man to dunk it over a man
jake paul can you jump over a month if
jake paul punches [__] out of him
he can just say afterwards yeah but
let's see you can jump over a man that
was the real
that's the real question that was the
real winner yeah i'll throw whatever you
want over this build
right this is impressive he's got a lot
of attributes that could make him a good
boxer footwork
power athleticism cardio sessions yeah a
lot of people will be going
why has jake paul agreed to fight this
guy
his video immediately after the
appointment yeah
it's called bryce hall is an idiot don't
two snakes watch jake paul's latest
video
smart i'm supporting nate robinson
i want may robinson to bash his tiny
head in
anyway kicked out the building eating
tricks with the tricks with the trick at
the bottom
this does look like a lot of fun oh yeah
absolutely yeah this is funny very much
yeah nothing dirty
sometimes i just love jumping up and
down around the studio yeah sometimes
brian and i'll just
just there's nothing more fun than that
i mean yeah lots more fun than jumping
up and down what's more fun than
annoying the neighbours yeah yeah
they love it yeah exactly you'll see
i've had fun because of my hair uh so
his videos coming out same day as ksi
interestingly you see the tweet jake
paul said best of luck and
gg just replied [__] off ksi is online
chatting
urban and yoblin he tried to make it a
competition between him and i on like
who is gonna get more views on our music
video
i'm not too worried about it and i told
him i was gonna wish him the best of
luck so ksi
good [__] luck buddy he didn't talk
about the bit where he told him to [__]
off interesting
funny this is the thing i i actually uh
don't think jake paul's talent this in
music called me crazy i think certain
songs have been very decent for youtube
standards right very good
yeah yeah sure so i wanted to send my
team out into public to play people the
song to get their genuine reactions
without knowing it was me
what up guys we're back at santa monica
what the [__] is that
sort of um diet logan a few years ago i
tried to dress cool like this
i stopped because i realized it just
doesn't suit you i forgot that my face
doesn't look like pharrell's genuinely i
was just thinking of pharrell
yeah that is so weird yeah no i like
this this is good i would listen to this
totally
one to ten dude i'd say ten ten this
woman's listening to other music and she
said that's a 10. i haven't heard it
laura
hasn't heard that right my badge i
haven't heard it you're right although i
heard that snippet and i thought
this is normal oh really
oh my god her face she's devastated yeah
maybe it's good maybe people do like it
i've already said i think he's pretty
decent jake
does current virus cause deafness lack
of taste is one of them so maybe
these guys are fighting each other on
the 12th of september i think wow
there's going to be an empty arena so
what's new nothing's different
because the arena would have been empty
anyway yeah because no one buys tickets
for things so
they're fighting a real uh athlete this
time jake is um it's a little bit like a
lose-lose for me because he's probably
gonna have a hard fight in this guy of
course he's a real athlete who probably
hasn't got the same boxing experience as
jake but you told me he's a bit of a
tough guy
you know he's tough yeah yeah so if jack
goes out there and smokes him that's a
real accomplishment
but with no name accomplishment to
towards it whereas like with the gabo
fight gabo had a name and that he had
the whole of the uk behind him at that
time so it was a powerful moment
i guess the upside is that you fight on
a mike tyson card and he
definitely proves that he is serious
about boxing at the very least
that's the point about this if you're
willing to find nate robinson you're
willing to take on a tough fight where
you know it could go the distance
because of cardio there's not a lot of
gain
exactly like money-wise he could afford
another youtuber
probably smoke like an easy youtuber and
made a shitload of money
this is not really gonna be like that so
for me i'm like
fair play jake paul like we just call
him whatever you want he
is taking boxing seriously and every
other youtube boxing match has been
for the payoff of the adulation you take
the other guy's fans you get big money
this doesn't really have a lot of these
upsides that everyone else has had so he
clearly loves boxing
and i respect that if this is a fight in
the middle
of his fight with ksi it means he's
going to be a bit more short by the time
he fights
ksi than what he would have been if he'd
had all of that time off if ksi has no
middle fight that means jj will have had
a long time off yeah what like a year
maybe yeah yeah
maybe 18 months yeah yeah whereas jake
will afford gibbel
for again and then for jj so what you
see with like conor mcgregor for example
is the sharper these guys are the better
they fight the longer they take off
usually the harder it is to stay
sharp so i credit him for actually being
serious about boxing what i'm more
interested in
is the my tyson come back i've got to be
honest i mean this is like michael
jordan playing one last game in the nba
even though it's not michael jordan in
his prime you still want to turn up
yeah wow he's lacing the gloves up
we're witnessing one of the greatest
ever whatever you believe you can
believe he's the greatest i'm not the
one mike tyson is an icon today as
boxers they grew up idolizing him
making was like tyson fury all of them
will be sitting down
and watching this like little kids
because they they he is their hero and
for jake paul to be able to say i was on
a mike tyson card that's pretty [__]
cool and i actually had another
boxer that we know might actually be on
that card but we'll see
um so interestingly roy jones jr is a
deaf
a bit quite a lot smaller than mike
tyson and they're sort of coming out and
saying you know it isn't going to be a
nasty vicious fight
it's like well there's an eight round
exhibition between two beasts
once one of them hurts the other one a
little bit the other one's gonna lash
out and
it wouldn't surprise me if someone
finishes the fight even though they're
saying they're not going for knockouts
what's the point then if you don't want
to go for the knockout and you don't
want to bring the dog back and you don't
want to be that guy
don't be that guy don't get in the ring
the only reason people want to say my
tyson
they want the ferocious mike tyson that
like i want to [__] eat your heart
kind of mike tyson
so if he's going to come back for this
one time go for it
you know and give people a show i'm
excited for the fight
to be honest i think we're going to do a
knockout for that you know mike tyson's
gonna fight
i never thought i'd be able to say we're
commenting on uh doing the live show
from mike tyson fighting
sick this sunday i'm doing a live porker
stream where i'm competing
in the tournament for possibly like a
minute i don't know possibly you gotta
look up the numbers i'm on true news and
i was um
i was in the middle of telling the
people how much is up for grabs in the
tournament this sunday
do you know yet if you're telling me a
guess i'm gonna say guess what it's
gonna be around 400k
what well you heard it here first guys
it's gonna be what did he say [__] loads
no he said probably 400 grand yeah so
i'm playing for 400 grand in attack
on sunday a share of four no the 400 is
the winner
no yeah the rest of it will be shared
out what my share of that
so the top 159 on last sunday's stream
meant i got 2 800 playing
poker against professionals wow i'm
playing against
over a thousand poker professionals i'm
learning on the fly we gotta poke our
expert with us charlie
carrell off the podcast as some of you
might remember this weekend we're going
for the big one we're going for the big
money be there
tg2 kanye's uh being kanye
i mean he's gone on a rant he's
basically alluding to the fact that meek
mill might have [__] kim kardashian i
don't think he alluded to the fact i
think he literally
in the tweets goes i've been trying to
get a divorce from kim
since she met meek mill in the waldorf
spelt wrong
to talk about prison reform maybe he's
throwing
the problem with kanye tweets is uh
kanye puts them up and then he takes
them down puts them up and he takes them
down puts them up and he takes them down
and then he'll tweet his
new album title and tracklist i just
don't know how much of this is real
anymore so here's the problem
kanye seemingly was going through an
episode
and as someone who's uh dad has bipolar
disorder and he has bipolar and i want
to
be empathetic towards the struggle that
someone like that could go through
because i know how hard it can be on
other family members
when someone's going through that stuff
kim kardashian puts out a beautifully
worded
instagram story where she's like you
know we just need a bit of empathy here
a bit of care and a bit of respect for
what we're actually going through
instead of people
pointing the finger and ha ha ha kanye
is losing his mind again i'm
all about that i completely agree with
that totally however the problem
is the timing why is it that kanye's
episodes
coincide consistently over the last five
years
with his album drops as a kanye west fan
i know for a fact that kanye goes
extremely private extremely public
extremely private extremely public i
don't think that these
episodes are to do with just being in
public
i think kanye's like this privately as
well i take your point
on that like you know that's just his
style but at the same time
he's exercising an awful lot of
self-control over the last few years
with that private public private public
style which always coincides with what
is going to make him the most money and
then when it seems like he's losing his
mind and he's going off the deep and
everyone's talking about it it always
benefits him to the absolute max
and given how clever the kim kardashian
machine
is and how he's now probably learned a
lot from those of how to exploit the
press of
no publicity as bad publicity it it
wouldn't surprise me if a lot of this is
contrived
and he is just i'll act a bit like this
during the album release and
get everyone talking it wouldn't
surprise me because of the level of
control he's exercised in the past
it doesn't really change what the end
product is either way though does it
because well the last album was shipped
yeah we get
sort of not great music at the moment
and um
the album this is the one that drew
involved in or is that the next one i
don't know whether dr dre has been
involved in donda
i'd guess so yeah i mean it would make
sense the fact that he's
naming the album after his mother is
very sweet and but also his organization
yeah and it's
it's you want that to go well for him
but him running for president
was clearly an absolute publicity stunt
i'm saying
and for me when your mental health is
also
wrapped up in that and it's the outburst
and it's the i i feel like it's all
coinciding together
it makes me think is that also part
publicity stunt and to me
when mental health is supposed to be
taken more seriously than ever
if it is proven to be that i think
people need to really come down hard on
him and the machine that they've created
i come down hard on the machine because
i personally look at even
other public figures who have run for
president in the past and you realize
that those people are basically the
front
for a very smart machine behind enable
this sort of behavior
and i think kanye's surrounded by a lot
of enablers as well
jeffree star has come out and had his
say after tarty threw him under the bus
and said that him and shane were the
ones who put her up to making
the buy sisters video what's up
everybody welcome back to my channel
now i've been silent for a very long
time i know that's very rare for me
it's easy to be silent for a very long
time when you're banned to write
that's a phrase in the uk for jeffrey if
he's watching this it doesn't mean
you've been banned by the right wing now
in the past i've been very guilty of
speaking
out of anger out of frustration out of
my emotions
all of these people start their video
but with with this they go now in the
past videos
i've made mistakes so this video is
different what i'm trying to do is get
you to forget all of the [__] fuck-ups
that i've made in the past so that now
you'll give me a chance
i mean people have the chance to evolve
but the problem is
you're trying to get someone to remove
from their memory
all the data that you've given them so
that they don't take into account what a
[__] you are i'm so quick to grab my
phone and just say whatever is on my
mind in that moment without ever
really thinking the ramifications of my
words this is a calculated attack is
what you're saying brilliant
but basically he was banked right so he
couldn't just come out and say that
didn't happen because clearly it did
happen and you can tell by shane's
reaction that it's exactly what happens
at no point was like you know this is
completely untrue at no point did he say
shane went oh
my god oh no yeah and for the first time
in a
very long time i'm really reflecting
on my behavior and mine alone imagine
living your life in such a way where you
go
first time in a long time i'm reflecting
on myself like a normal person
does that at very least weekly yeah a
normal person doesn't go for the first
time
in a long time i'm gonna question am i
an [__] that usually means
you're an [__] earlier we were saying
how people uh copy things
hold up yeah yeah are you yeah are you
seeing me transcendental zinger did it
at the same as well yeah did the same as
well i can't be bothered to explore the
words
are we trendsetters we inspire people to
sit down on a very comfortable chair
yes and say what's on their mind no one
who did that before us lawrence i
wouldn't be surprised if this video in
the next second
cuts to shane dawson crouching over a
microphone going were you sad when that
happened
and then they hug and then he buys him
with the place yeah
i've already strained yeah yeah yeah and
i've come to a lot of realizations
and it's been really important to
actually understand
everything that i was a part of that i
did wrong
um and really start a new chapter for
myself
you knew fine well what your actions
were doing
you knew the whole time what you were
doing you're just not a great person so
you didn't care
about that and now you've got to kind of
act like oh we did i didn't realize
because that's your only hope out of
this so that your fans don't fully
comprehend what a complete [__] you are
but unfortunately
there's people out there like myself who
see you right through this [__] just
gonna be absolutely clear here jeffrey
started 34. you look good for 34 jeffrey
although
you know when i filmed my video called
never doing it again i meant every word
in the video
did i slip up am i human have i done
some [__] up things
of course i have i'm never doing that
again genuinely i've messed up all right
i've messed up that is such a way of
just letting yourself off with
everything it's amazing he literally
said i wouldn't do this i meant it have
i slipped up am i human
yeah the sentence before he goes i will
be making no excuses the next sentence
he goes i said i'd never do it again but
i'm human
and i'm like that's an excuse you're
making them already within the next
sentence that's unbelievable i thought
you were self-reflective jeffrey i
believed you you sucked me in
for everyone saying jeffrey's gonna be
coming with the receipts and we all need
to
be get ready to forgive that is the
opposite of who i am i know i'm dramatic
i'm crazy at times i'm outspoken
because tati said that these are all the
things he holds over people in the
community
she checkmated him she she blocked him
in to a point where now he can't use all
of those things because
he will then just prove that she was
right all along
yeah so she [__] him over so bad that
the only way out for jeffrey
in the next video was to do this sort of
[__] i know this may sound shocking
coming from my mouth
but when you accept that you are the
problem you can become the solution
it doesn't sound shocking at all it's
just like i don't believe you when you
say it when you accept that you are the
problem you can become the solution
that sounds very threatening absolutely
yeah i'm gonna solve you
i'm about to solve you [__] we're
solving all your [__] problems
i have moments where i get fired up i
don't think things through i don't think
about how my actions will affect others
while i'm saying them she does though or
he does whatever
i'm not being nasty here i just don't
know what he identifies as he does know
his actions will have an impact that's
why he's doing them he's pleading
ignorance because he doesn't want
everyone to be aware you're just a bad
person
right in your core where your black
heart lives in your chest
you're a bad person the sentence before
this he literally said i have impulse
control
the sentence after he says sometimes i
just say things i don't mean
i didn't try to take anyone down i'm not
a villain in a movie
this isn't a netflix series with a crazy
storyline
believe me i've watched a lot of netflix
it's nowhere near that level not even on
youtube level this is pretty bad
this is actually boring yeah the best
thing is he goes this isn't a netflix
series dumb writer doesn't but then the
next sentence i know it sounds like it
and trust me i'm sure i'd watch it as
well he somehow managed to big himself
up
in that way he goes he's like this is
not dramatic or interesting at all but
believe me i would watch that
believe me like you know if it was i'm
pretty sure it could be
it
just to be clear netflix people often
get murdered dumped in a sort of river
somewhere
the body turns up 10 years later and
we've got to find out how that happened
retrace that's evidence it's very very
interesting it's very dark it's very
worrying it's about human nature
it's it's about the darkest thing that
the implant does on the family right
the victims this on the other hand i
mean jeffree star and shane dawson just
got in the tattoo
and said yeah can you torpedo that
little bastard's uh makeup line because
he's really costing us some money here
yeah i mean that is literally it
here's the thing though brian if when
you're wrong you go
it's more complex than that everyone
goes ah it's more complex than that ah
there's more to it
right self-refreshing sorry yeah it's
more complex than that right we have to
all take accountability for our own
actions and no one else's and that's
what i will continue to do
continue sorry no point has he said
i was the one who got in tattoos here
and said torpedo his
uh jeff james james is [__] i don't
know i don't know
no point is he taking accountability i
know we're analyzing this we'll pull
this apart the eye test on this for me
is that this is an angry
unself-reflective person absolutely
who's actually making an angry
threatening video
towards you who gets away with
everything yeah because they're
surrounded by a bunch of like yes men
[__] and they're
and they're rich they make a lot of
money for people that's the problem that
jeffrey is not actually pointing out
buying this guy's makeup like as if he's
a good person he's a bad person
let's be honest here brian he's a nasty
piece of [__] exactly you can be a nasty
person
and make good makeup you can make bad
makeup and be a good person
making good makeup and making bad makeup
does not make you a good or bad
but realistically these youtube lot
they're only buying the makeup because
they're like this guy
oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah they're not
making it what does he do yeah i mean
literally are you brain dead yeah well
some people buy no hoodies
did i get caught up in the hype did i do
dumb [__] and did i
not just simply call james charles and
ask questions myself
100 you didn't do that because you
wanted him to be taken down right you
purposefully did not ask because you
were pushing the agenda
to [__] this guy's career over you
didn't want to know the truth you didn't
care about the truth you cared about
getting what you wanted out that
situation
it wasn't dumb it wasn't ignorant it was
evil
you targeted him and you went after him
now accept that admit that and say
i was a [__] person for that you want
the truth you can't handle the truth
we delivered that but it was one person
in the movie that did it but we did it
better split this split it
and i think that james and myself and
anyone involved would agree with me that
there are way
bigger issues happening on this planet
another great thing is diversion tactics
when you're wrong and
it's halfway through the video and he's
already gone like done that now yeah
it's is that it
here's diversion tactics if you punch
someone in the face and then they go why
did you do that and you go
climate change is a big issue all right
we need to worry about climate
bang we need to worry about climate
change the person is still standing
there with a bleeding nose
all right and that in that moment
they're going i don't think climate
change is my immediate worry that's what
he's doing he's going to they're much
bigger you try to wreck someone's
[__] life yes there are other things
going on in the world you haven't
addressed it he hasn't accepted anything
no and now he's just moving on yeah so
i'm not going to give you an expose of
the beauty community i'm not going to
end anyone today i've never blackmailed
anyone in my life i've never committed a
crime before and i've never been to jail
that nasty stuff wasn't good though that
nazi stuff wasn't great
he did nazi makeover and that was clear
at the same time he talks about ending
people
i still feel like he has that
information he's sort of sitting
let's just be clear here he tried to end
james charles and
failed just because he didn't succeed
doesn't mean he hasn't blackmailed or
ended people like he went to do we can't
say if he's blackmailed someone now
legally we can't say
[__] this right just like last year have
fully removed myself
and did i get swept up into the [__]
again of course i did
you started it i got swept up who did
the sweeping
you you so just to be clear he's removed
himself from this
absolutely he might have got swept up in
it yeah because him himself
swept himself into it yeah but now he's
removed himself sorry
if everyone else could just deal with
the [__] storm he's left behind because
he's not involved i don't need this in
my life
i'm involved i'm all about positivity
now i'm all i'm i'm living for the day
living for the moment living for me 2020
was really hard yeah it says on my wall
over there live love laughs yeah so
my mansion yeah yes definitely sorry
i've got to take the dogs out for a walk
and by that i mean my dog walkers have
to when i'm watching
right that's actually really good i'd do
that from a balcony as well you don't
want to be around the normal people
did a little [__] there yeah poopy poops
brianna taylor
still has no justice black trans women
are being murdered every day and the
news is
silent elijah mcclain has no justice
and the countless other people who are
murdered every single day while everyone
just goes about their business
like nothing's happening that was you
when you were busy wrecking other
people's lives
what is next you guys know jeffree star
cosmetics
will never be slowing down he actually
managed to promote the cosmetics yeah
just to be absolutely clear doesn't
matter what kind of [__] up [__] i do
i still need to make as much money as
humanly possible
so right we now do merch right it took
us long enough but we got there we tried
imagine
we we were doing an apology video and
halfway through the video we quit the
apology
the apology was terrible we then go on
[__] black lives matter
in a completely unrelated subject as if
to say all right well now
this is more important you take trying
to take the moral high ground it's clear
as day what the [__] you're doing
and then at the end if anyone was
believing
that you really care about black lives
matter you then turn from that
which is an important subject yeah and
go back to your [__] mate
your own match if anyone is actually
dumb enough to believe that this is
sincere
wow but what's coming next is one of my
most exciting projects ever
and i can't wait um august is going to
be
very exciting yep absolutely
guys i just need you to know i've been
in my cave for a little while i need to
make some money now
do you know what it is right a few years
ago i feel like youtube was
full of people who were completely out
of touch with reality
the influences at the very very top you
could see were just so rich
and people weren't pulling them up and
they were living these bizarre lives and
doing these bizarre things and since
then so many of them have been forced to
come down to planet earth and have been
absolutely blasted and what amazes me is
this guy's still
out in the clouds he has no concept of
reality he is not in the real world at
all
august though it's going to be an
amazing month so you look at james
charles
james charles is a bona fide star
whatever reason whatever you think about
him the guy is a star maybe don't say
boner with this guy being 20 years older
than james charles you can imagine the
feelings of jealousy he was having as
this shooting star came out of nowhere
and was clearly on the trajectory to
overtake geoffrey no problem better
jawline better hair i mean just better
everything kim kardashian you can
imagine
the the feelings of how threatened he
would have been by james charles so he
went after him
and now for him he has to apologize to
james
publicly because he knows james has
beaten him because the one with the the
audience the one with the
the star quality all of that will come
out on top in these situations and
generally james is just a better human
being this guy sheer khan
he didn't expect simba yeah to have come
back james charles and this is simba
though overall i don't think james
charles is simber i think he's probably
closer to null
now moving on this is a couple of weeks
old i just think you've got an opinion
on it it's been a while people have been
asking us to comment on it uh will smith
jada pick it did you've all seen it the
chat she basically admits she cheated on
it
is it cheating or was it like they were
open and then they had a brief spell
where they were like drifting apart and
she got [__] by august i mean it
really feels like he
she [__] him to be fair i mean they
both [__] each other just like jeffrey
said
august is going to be great apparently
who was that must be a tough month for
them in that
household august 20th yeah exactly can
we just call it
is it august 30th yet something else not
yet you and i
decided we were gonna take our space and
what happened
yeah and then i got into an entanglement
with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
that's the word that's the word that
people are entanglement
apparently august is actually working on
he's a music guy he's working on a song
called entanglement
cash in on it fair player the august
thing i didn't i've got to admit he's
really the booty call in this it's like
uh it's weird seeing a man in this
position it's also weird for me because
if you get involved with a couple that
you know are famous
in a relationship and extremely private
how is it your business to go on someone
else's show and go
yeah i was uh kind of [__] i feel
like he's the [__] in this
like he's the guy who's [__] them both
up no maybe they [__] themselves because
they had an open relationship
they're a very strong couple so maybe
they're strong enough to overcome this
but the problem is when you feel
humiliated by the other person
it's very very difficult to move forward
will now
as a man i think it's a bit harder even
as a man because
we're we've got egos you know for the
whole world to know
another guy went in that [__] wow i mean
you know put it better respectfully
because he's just like he's now gonna
try and hold his head high when
everyone's talking about
yeah but august hit that [__] you know
what i mean so awkward
especially when you're will [__]
smith like make no mistake about it in
my lifetime
there's not many actors celebrities
sportsmen
who have reached the level of like will
smith
at a point in time will smith was the
biggest star on the planet at one point
in time that's of
like and not just for like a minute
we're talking about 20 years of
dominance
on screen we're talking about fresh
prince being the show that every single
kid in the world watched
we're talking about independence there
men in black we're talking about
classics
will smith have more than one summer
should we put it that way there was
fresh prince into independence day into
other films and then just
men in black but what i mean is it's
summer yeah but it's summer after summer
after summer it lasted for such a long
20 years i think 20 years of like
being number one you know what i mean
like not only is she having an impact on
will smith with what she's saying that
she did but
will smith is an icon especially for the
black community and she is sort of
cutting his balls off
live on tv and that is it's not just
going to impact will smith
it's impacting everyone who idolizes
will smith it's that mufasa moment isn't
it you're like oh
he used to be the guy and now he's just
he's the same as everyone else but is
that not a good thing in some ways
it is because it's unhealthy for us to
think that bad [__] doesn't happen to
like big celebrities either
you don't want to watch the fresh prince
to have his woman [__] in front of him
you know the real question is
did we need to know this and the answer
no unless he's into that of course in
which case
i've had a horse i was in a lot of pain
and i was very broken
now in the process big lack of eye
contact from
jada versus will being very focused on
her right yeah
um when og first came around he was he
was
really sick he was really really sick
yeah
and the outpouring
for him from our family was
initially about his health will's not
trying to do this but he's really
painting a picture now with we as a
family welcome this guy
yeah our children yeah me the husband
and now this guy who's come in ends up
[__] the mother
cooking just imagine the pain that this
must have caused that family they're not
acknowledging it
will's giving her a free pass for
whatever reason but that is painful
and i mean we found all those different
resources
you know to help pull them through and
god you can almost feel the thought from
will
in his head there yeah he's got a very
expressive the way he's looking at her
you can say he's thinking
he wants to shout i feel like there's a
not in an aggressive way but in a pain
he's got this look on his face like i'm
in pain hearing this we decided that we
were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to make myself
well at that particular point in time it
was indefinite
yeah i really felt like we could be over
yeah
no we were over there's a lot of
miscommunication there where he's saying
i felt like we could be over and she
keeps going yeah
but as far as i was concerned we were
done and he's like yeah but not so much
for me i still was like it feels like
there were two different states of mind
i kind of feel like they're both trying
to control their side of the
conversation so he goes i felt like we
were over and she was like oh oh we were
over yeah
so they both she's out of the position
peyton does the cheater
clearly was from this conversation the
fact that
he was there when august came in and
their family welcomed this guy in
clearly he should never have like if
it was that much distance between it and
it was you would never just [__] this
guy
having him in the house with your
current husband
you can think what you want out there
but like as far as i'm saying the fact
that he
was aware of this whole situation proves
how close this was to an actual
ongoing marriage you know as time went
on
i got into a different kind of
entanglement really got to stop using
that word because it's really not
i mean it is a good word but it's not a
good word it's not because she doesn't
want to say the word affair because she
doesn't want to feel like
she is a cheater classic [__]
tactics from someone in a [__]
relationship where they don't want to be
the bad guys she doesn't want to be the
bad guy here
is there really a bad guy here like she
[__] up yeah but it's the fear of that
label that makes me really uncomfortable
from this like it makes me think
you just don't want to own up to what
you did so you're calling it
entanglement because you just don't want
to own up
right during that time launched into an
interaction
with august what do you feel like um
you were looking for that question is
steeped in
what was i not giving you of course yeah
that's all he's asking what we're not
getting from you
are you not getting from me and that
from him is a personal thing of why him
over me and that clearly
he gave you something that i couldn't
that is the pain
and kind of credit to both of them for
having the bottle
to do this publicly because it must be
[__] hard but what amazed me about it
was
as two people in over 20 year marriage
how poor they are communicating with
each other about their feelings is
surprising
i'm surprised they've lasted as long as
they've had right because the way this
conversation went
it's so dysfunctional it's so difficult
to listen to
because they're both dancing around
truths and if you can't be that honest
with each other
after this length of marriage when
you're publicly admitting that you
[__] other people or whatever else has
happened
you still have a lot of work to do then
is that the problem with being
a power couple and not just a couple the
struggle is over the power and i see a
lot of that at this table yeah both of
them guys are trying to dictate the
narrative correct
yeah big time yeah but they're bad at
getting their points across
actually i'm like they're both smart
people why is this such a challenge for
you guys it feels quite passive
aggressive to me
a lot of this conversation feels very
sort of what were you
yeah the pressure that this is causing
neither of them just put their heart out
there and just really went for
it they're both being very careful about
what they admit and it's like well if
you were going to do this kind of chat
publicly then [__] do it
don't half do it do it right and this to
me is a lot of them holding back a
little bit because they don't want to
come across as that person that
you know entanglement all right we don't
know what that really means or
him going what did august get from what
did august give you that you were
looking for realistically
what did i not give you i'm hurting this
is hard i just
wanted to feel good it had been
so long
since i felt good new dick will do that
for you
well yeah although yeah i get the other
side of it 20 years younger than will
probably is he like 15 years younger
sure he'd be hitting that pounding that
[__] and it was really a joy
to just help heal somebody was that what
she was saying as she was making his
dick
really hard yeah i'm healing you i am
healing you
his penis there's something about that
childhood trauma
um that feels as though it can be
fixed through fixing people
she's coming out of things that i'd feel
like new discoveries about herself
and realistically this is why you need a
soul
search this is why you need
self-reflection and i feel like people
who are
rich in power who are told that
everything they do is great don't do
enough of that because they're just
coasting
when you see her having this sort of wow
moment of 48 years old it's like yeah
you should have known that about
yourself when you were 30
realistically like i mean if you you
know my husband i'm
now i got to be with you at the press
conference while you like
to tell the world about your
transgressions
laughing is so awkward
people have been married for over 20
years and yet they are still
so awkward around each other and the
communication is so difficult for them
it's like why you should have no secrets
at all you should know each other inside
out like there should be no
tension like that right i'm gonna get
you back first
and then you're gonna get me back i
think you've got me back
i think you've been just gonna bring up
the there we go
okay so a lot of people think he's shag
mog or robbie no
way did he though like there's no proof
of that you know what i mean
what what makes people say that i don't
know rumors
okay i think we're good on that okay
you don't need to go there anymore okay
let's just say it's not gonna be another
suicide squad if you know what i'm
saying
speaking of suicide squad should we
check up on galaine maxwell she
the weird thing is she is um not an ugly
woman particularly
you know what i mean zoom in again yes
prince andrew one of the royal family
with a young woman and who's that in the
background
gizzagle maxwell yeah she's with a lot
of these what glenn maxwell who they
recently arrested because they thought
she was entangled
with this man over here jeffrey epstein
the man who killed himself
yeah she's jeffrey epstein's hemp dress
you know what i mean she's the one who
got the
young women to him and basically
convinced them to
do whatever she told them to is that
donald trump
it is donald trump did you say that the
fox news cut that out of the
post this exact picture here where they
cropped donald trump
left in ivanka it's gonna [__] you over
that isn't it well it is because donald
trump
in his last interviews just admitted he
actually knows her very well
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i haven't been following it too much
you've not been following an
international story of which someone you
are very good friends with
you know very well is implicated in
child sex trafficking yeah probably
wouldn't pay attention to it either i
wouldn't pay attention
imagine you knew someone who was going
through that you'd be like following
every [__] day of it to be fair he's
been very busy coming up with a mask
that can cover his face because no one
else before had thought of a mask
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach uh but
i wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it no one
mentioned it
no one mentioned it but he hasn't been
following it you know
do you know are you thinking of galen
maxwell now i haven't really been
following it i must say
um it is tricky though because the whole
andrew did you mention andrew well i
didn't mention andrew right well i mean
i'd assume he might be involved i've not
been following i'm gonna be following it
but i assume
yeah why do you assume that donald trump
have you ever been to pizza express just
to be clear
this this is my main problem with this
whole situation aside from the fact that
this is the president of the united
states yeah a man who sweats
imagine someone you were friendly with
and had met
numerous times yeah photographed with
you is then going
on trial for being involved in crimes
against children sex trafficking right
would you be saying to people that you
knew when they asked you about
said trial i wish her well especially if
you claim you haven't been following it
don't know all the details don't really
know that would you not
keep that to yourself and go i don't
want to comment on it at this time
at least because you don't want to
either say the wrong thing potentially
say something positive towards her
and find out that she's a terrible
person why would you
send positive words to someone who may
be guilty of that potentially
why would you do that yeah you go it's
an ongoing case i don't really think i
should uh be commenting on that right
here's the thing
why would you do that though and this is
an honest genuine question right why is
he saying
i wish her well to the notorious girl in
maxwell yeah i hope the death is
painless
i've said too much i was on the fence
but i was like okay clearly jeffrey
epstein was dealing with a lot of big
powerful people some
evil sick and twisted dudes but the
likelihood is is donald trump just
someone he used to have a few drinks
with because they were mixing in the
same crowd
is it likely that donald trump will get
mixed up in this probably not he's
president you know he's probably not
that deeply involved
he's a respectable figure now because
he's gone i wish her well i'm like oh
you're sending her positivity
you're [__] yourself that she's
going to implicate you you're covering
her impression you're covering her ass
completely the old paddock
yeah the panic stations are on something
we should add here while we are
joking about a situation which is
horrible someone's son has also died
over this and it's the son
of the new judge who's dealing with the
jeffrey epstein case there is no way
that this isn't related a gunman who
shot and killed 20 year old son of
us federal judge and wounded the judge's
husband in an attack of their home the
shootings occurred in new jersey home
but her only child as well
yeah oh [__] that is awful it's a very
sad situation when obviously you see
someone's
uh son being killed and it's even more
sinister
when you see the cases these people are
dealing with so this is just further
evidence of the fact that this is one of
the most corrupt cases we will ever see
in our lifetime there are so
many big powerful people implicated you
know the suicide of jeffrey epstein
which obviously stinks
and then the fact that the judge who's
residing over the
case is then having his son shot at her
home like i mean this is corruption at
the highest level the fact that the
justice system in america is there to
bring people like this to justice
and you've got them the people involved
in the system getting their kids shot
and killed over it like how can you
believe in that system
yeah it's [__] whilst we're here let's
just very quickly
cover donald trump's expert handling of
uh wearing a mask
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
something i don't like saying about
things but that's the way it is it's the
way
it's what we have you look over the
world it's all over the world yeah it's
been getting better over here all over
the world
that's coronavirus right now and i like
it i like it i like it
if you can use the mask when you can use
the mask
if you're close to each other if you're
in a group i would put it
on when i'm in a group again he's sort
of wishy-washy it's like just wear the
[__] mask don't say
sometimes maybe when you can just wear
it my frustration with the mustang comes
out of the fact that it's now become
like
law to have to wear it on buses on
trains whatever i've got people coming
up to me going like you gotta put the
mask on and stuff like that i had an
awkward moment the other day i realized
my mask
broke i was like [__] now what yeah yeah
i've got a big face
and and then they were like uh oh say
realistically we're supposed to actually
throw you off the train now and i'm like
well if you want to try this effort
i did think if you want to try and do
that make my [__] day but my main
thing
my main thing with the sebastian england
i think we've got about 40 odd thousand
people dead now
45 and we've chosen now that the deaths
are
at an all-time low the daily debts are
in an all-time low since corona started
we
now have implemented mass squaring as
law they're saying this is the best
thing for it and i'm not disputing that
it is honestly maybe it is right i'm not
a scientist and i take
on board what they're saying but it's
like why are we making it lawn now he's
late for that like it feels like boris
has turned up with a fire extinguisher
ready the house has burned down boris
yeah you you've made it low
now the vast majority of people who will
die from corvid have
already died that is a fact yeah right
and that's what i love
no he's like the masks will rescue
[__] me how long has it taken us to
[__] work this out and now he's made
it low this is pointless at this
at this stage i mean yes we'll still
save some people but by comparison to
what it could have done
if you've just done this four [__]
months ago man less people are dying
from it now though yes that's because
most of the people who are gonna die
from it have already died americans
though may be surprised at your change
of tone
some more perhaps realistic tone some
would look at it that way
the sudden embrace of masks the same
thing is happening in america is
happening in the uk
in that is politicians are being forced
to completely 180 and flip-flop on their
previous statements
because as we've all now been shown to
be absolutely true
they didn't have a [__] clue what
they were doing not a clue
so any of you are thinking that these
are the people that trust right now
you need to rethink it like yeah because
thousands of people die because of the
negligence of these politicians
yeah as one family we mourn every
precious
life that's been lost i pledge in
their honor that we will develop a
vaccine donald trump is now using dead
people's lives
to try to rally people behind the cause
all of these people have died we're
gonna do it
in their name we wouldn't need to do it
in
anyone's name or very few people's name
if you'd have treated it this seriously
in the first place
but sadly you're all about image and not
about substance
moving on from that to another very sad
story um the glee actress nya rivera was
also
uh found dead this really got me a bit
so they had a boat and they were in uh
i think a river of sort of some sort
what it sounds like is
she got caught up in difficult uh waters
to swim in
she managed to swim hard as hell save
her son's life she pushes him back onto
the boat
by that point she couldn't swim anymore
and she's gone under now that tells you
as someone who's swam
in difficult waters many many many times
the level of exhaustion she would have
been at to
not be able to save herself to use every
last bit of energy that she
had to push her child to safety and save
his life
and then be so exhausted she's gone
under after that i've talked about
diving before but i'll get [__]
serious now i actually understand how
hard that would have been
i was actually reading the story and i'm
like i was going through it my head like
almost crying like the level of love
that she has had to
use to power herself to save her kid's
life to a point of exhaustion and then
go
under herself almost immediately after
her kids had he seen
her go [__] me water can be so dangerous
and people need to fully understand like
how bad it can be and how dangerous it
is secondly a mother's love
is uh the most powerful thing in the
world and uh her final act was to
give her own life to save a kid's life
so what a woman
it's just one of the saddest stories
you'll [__] hear and the glee curse
uh as you know that's the whole thing
now people talk about these three actors
who've now died in a
one of the bigger shows on tv at the
time it was one of the it was the
biggest kids show on television wasn't
it and you had i think it
it got such a wide audience yeah yeah it
was uh older people younger people yeah
it was quite a fast it felt family
friendly yeah very family friendly which
and some of the darkness of the death i
mean this one as sad as it is
is very um it was wholesome you know she
gave her life for a child whereas the
other two guys uh one was a heroin
overdose and he was like the heartthrob
of the show
and then the other one was real [__]
dark because he was a pedo lot in prison
who then killed himself they found
[__] all sorts on his computer and
his his girlfriend crossed him up
basically saying i'm telling you he's a
[__] pedo and
it all came out and he killed himself in
prison like when you think of how
wholesome glee was as a show
[__] you know r.i.p uh nia uh rivera
i did watch a couple of episodes with
her in uh she was like you know
movie star just written all over and
yeah she got that kind of uh
face and demeanor yeah it's just super
sad
now we don't really need to tell you
much else than this
exact picture this boy had over 90
stitches in his face
after he got between a dog which was
attacking his sister and his sister
and he got her to safety and you can see
there the damage done is
pretty brutal yeah and you gotta commend
such a young boy for his bravery oh my
this guy deserves a medal
you like genuinely what a little legend
he's getting a captain in america she's
being told i don't know who the [__]
owned the dog but you need a [__]
punch clearly
the dog wasn't you know brought up
properly or being restrained properly at
the time
but credit to him he's a little uh hero
i mean that is that is the definition of
a hero because you know
when dogs go like that and clearly his
little sister would have lost her life
he risked his
so what a like little star he's getting
all the messages from all the big social
media stars do you wanna they could
probably genuinely yes that's great it's
a beautiful story and like he will have
that score probably for the rest of his
life and everyone will know him as the
kids
just to be clear how old does he six in
about 12 years or so son this score is
gonna help you so much
right all right sure you are the man
unless you're asexual you know i mean
even then it's probably gonna
do identify however you want however you
want whatever camco porn video yeah i
just thought this was quite a funny
video of cams show them a bit of love
what
kamkirka made a funny video it does
happen every now and then it doesn't
sound right
in this video me and my girlfriend are
going to buy four youtubers
only fans and rate them starting with
the least explicit
and ending the video with the most
explicit
how does that fit what do you think of
chloe she's lovely
yeah they're perfect for each other the
fact that she can tolerate him
i find her she deserves a medal yeah
mother teresa
yeah we have the queen trisha peters
people keep telling me to eat my
vegetables bit of me with mother nature
filling
all my holes in your inbox
[Music]
i really want to i'm kind of curious
here only fans trisha
paytas a few moments later oh my
god oh there's adam 22 huh is that adam
22 honestly i'm not attracted to this
well yeah but i hope they check trisha
over before this
she does proper pokemon what speak up
[__] i'm paying money
somewhere someone's knocking at the door
treasury let's go it might be a package
don't [__] touch this you make me
feel dirty her tits look really
different than normal boobs is it the
fact that the nipples look like they've
been painted on
what is she doing why is it doing that
what am i doing in there with that
i can't believe she's an actual youtube
influencer and this is what she makes
she's a squirt okay that's very
intelligent the way she's done that yeah
so she's put a glass box in front of
over the camera and then squirts on the
glass box so you can see all the squirt
happening
to be fair to trisha what i will say is
a lot of apparently
a lot of people who sell stuff on only
fans they do like you know a few
pictures or whatever right she goes
hardcore
she's fully committed yeah so if if
you're wanting to see like the full
thing
she'll show you everything you know what
i mean internal so this weekend
let's start playing manchester united
and potentially the winner will likely
get champions league football
so we've gone and got the biggest
baddest leicester fan
on the planet to guest star on the
kickoff
live on sunday
the kick off sunday but for now let's
see what he's been up to yeah right
folks we are back with another beer
garden
the beer garden so he's branded it yeah
the beer garden i just know that this
has got elliot written all over it yeah
yeah call it the piano and it's gone you
call it the beer garden you're gonna get
brands to send you free beer he's gone
free beer he's gone absolutely he's gone
i'll call it the beer garden yeah this
is it but you can bet your life now
no no it's not meant to be raining
anyway they ain't meant to be raining i
wonder if this guy is being roped into
it because like you know when dave says
normally fancy coming out and having a
bit of a nap i heard from the camera
he's like yeah but now it's it's the br
garden it's top hole
yeah well this is this guy's negotiating
himself twenty percent of them
i do feel like he's behind the scenes
going you know we'll work this out
yeah exactly we'll build a brand
together he probably the thing is
the sad thing for this guy is his living
room faces
dave's conservatory and there's times
where he's just trying to watch tv
windows open and he just sees dave at
the you're right
yeah and he's gone you're coming out
you're coming out watching cash in the
attic
but yeah all right yeah we'll do an
episode of the beer garden
[__] yeah all right dave let's move
that's not supposed to be [__] things
like this now then hold on
right that way oh there we go i'll put
masks on yeah
is that how they solved the problem look
at that can you see that folks
dave's basically insinuating that these
are sex dolls
that were at the football dave's mind
watch what dave's mind does here thumbs
up
or wanky hand yeah a lot that one's
standing the ones like that
now is she doing that or she doing that
look unbelievable
they've dressed them up and erect
nipples and everything
again dave's doing middle-aged man
outrage so he can get a nice long look
at the sex dolls he's going oh no
those are wrecked nipples oh disgusting
do you know erect nipples thing is i can
actually believe that fc soul
[__] up they've not done it on purpose
they've tried because when all said and
done these kind of the korean people in
that
soul isn't career yeah it is i have to
think sometimes
you know they are not the kind of people
who would do that
then today if there's one thing that
dave knows is the kind of people that
the
koreans are yeah because he's like it is
in korea isn't it
they are not the kind of people yeah if
i know that if i know someone what the
hell do i do yeah and bloody hell have i
studied korea as one thing seoul is in
korea isn't it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i have to think
sometimes yeah well
yeah because i mean even their porn is
all blurred out isn't it on the
important bits how can you do anything
to that when they've got it all
pixelated out porn is all bloody i
wouldn't know he would know
he lived there yeah exactly yeah he is a
master of this fc
soul would have all right let's try and
get this problem let's try and get an
atmosphere i know we'll get a load of
moaning sex dolls oh
oh we're attacking uh i love when dave
gets on a little bit
and his mate doesn't even look at him
dave's just entertaining himself can i
just say though i really would
appreciate if this sunday
when lester are attacking yeah
and i went into my granddad's house and
i went we were talking about work he
said and i says oh i'm supporting
scotland
and he went absolutely [__] ape [__]
at me
and i'm going well what's wrong with
that and he says because she's not
scottish you're english
yeah england oh yeah we've gone
he says it says um
he says i love it this doesn't even put
him off to one side he doesn't go i'll
stop sorry for a second he goes and he
says
he says he's trying to just tell them
that uh june's had to run in
as the the backup yeah you know i mean
she's trying to hold it down
so anyway that's better back in the beer
garden
just stood in the exact same place by
the fence
but i would also say right yeah like
that they weren't you like the patriots
with the americans sorry who's that i
don't remember the women being involved
in the vietnam garden that's a very good
point of the new edition i'm not sure
i'm all right with this well gene chimes
i wanted her to be
seen not heard right okay just like
dave's granddad i want i want june in a
bikini
as the ring card girl every 10 minutes
what are you doing
why and explaining 10 minutes right 20
minutes i don't want to
talk during this is mental right why do
we reduce june down to a sexual object
she's much more than that she's
disgraceful behind every strong man
behind every blue van man
there is a blue van woman all right
you've made a good party i take like
what i've said
i want her as the other guest because
kiwi is offering nothing yeah we've
heard enough of dave there i love dave
uh and i love hearing all those views
for more it's blue valman's youtube
channel you can check that out yeah it's
very good see you sunday for that as
well yeah so we got dave down on sunday
as we said
on the kickoff it's leicester manchester
chelsea all
trying to get champions league football
we got rory we got kg and we've got blue
van man they're
all sweating yeah under that um unlike
prince andrew
and then following that it's me on a
poker live stream trying to win
hundreds of thousands of dollars it
might happen i got close last time i got
down to the last 159 maybe this time
i'll get loud to the last one
so good luck good luck to you gonna need
it charlie carrell will be there as well
yeah we've got charlie big charlie in
the building
uh get your marvelous out in in the tg2
chat when
when we see him so we're basically live
streaming all of sunday afternoon
see you there it's been a good one yeah
thank you very much for having me don't
forget to hit the like button
stay subscribed to the trujillo youtube
channel
and we'll see you later